Il est riche, il est célèbre, il est visionnaire, et pourtant, il suit pas Bigflo et Oli ! *rire forcé*
ELON MUSK ! Les amis, je suis content, parce que aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler  d'une personnalité
qui est incroyable et à la fois j'aime, à la fois j'aime.. et je déteste, c'est trop bizarre.
Qui est Elon Musk ?
C'est l'une des personnes les plus riches des Etats Unis, sa fortune  personnelle est estimée à 22 milliards d'Euros
Il est dans le même délire, vous savez, y a Jef Bezos qui a Amazon, vous savez
toutes ces personnalités la qui ont étés visionnaires, qui ont créés un truc incroyable
Et qui sont devenues très riches grâce à ça, et bah il en fait partie.
Pour vous dire à quel point c'est un ouf, à 12 ans, il créé un jeu vidéo qu'il revend à 500 dollars. A 12 ans !
*Rire* Ton fils il fait ça à 12 ans mec, tu te grattes le crâne comme ça, jusqu'à perdre tes cheveux
et avoir une calvitie, et tu te dis : Oh m*rde, comment vais-je maîtriser mon enfant ?
A 24 ans, il créé Zip 2 avec son frère
C'est une start up qui vise à aider les médias notamment les journaux à se développer sur le web
On dans les années 95 à ce moment-là donc c'est déjà visionnaire de se dire
Oulala internet arrive, ça va changer le game de la presse
on va aider les entreprises
Bref ! Il vend ça pour combien ? 307 000 000$
La même année, il créé x.com qui est l'une des premières banques en ligne
maintenant il y en a beaucoup mais à l'époque, il n'y en avait qu'une
qu'il revend 1 500 000 000$
et qui plus tard fusionnera avec une autre boîte pour devenir le célèbre Paypal
avec lequel tu fais des dons à tes streamer préférés
*Rot*
Et enfin et là on rentre dans le coeur du sujet
A 31 ans, il créé SPACEX parce qu'il veut empecher l'extinction de l'humanité
et il veut amener des humains sur Mars
et il veut aussi être le premier à faire du tourisme spatial
c'est-à-dire à envoyer des gens normaux comme nous
dans l'espace.
Voilà pour s'amuser
Bref, aux US ils l'appellent Tony Stark parce que tout comme Tony Stark il est extrêmement riche,
il fait un peu ce qu'il veut, dès qu'il a une idée il va au bout
et il se kiffe
il est un peu égocentrique mais bon c'est comme ça
Alors je vous ai parlé de ses débuts mais Spacex c'est devenu un truc de ouf
puisque la NASA travaille avec Spacex
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'Elon Musk s'est dit p*tain mais c'est relou de perdre le lanceur quand on lance une fusée
parce qu'arrivée à une certaine altitude, le lanceur se détache puisqu'il est lourd et il ne sert plus à rien
et il se désintègre dans l'atmosphère
Donc du coup faut le reconstruire à chaque fois ce lanceur
et ça coûte cher
Elon Musk qu'est-ce qui s'est dit ?
mais on va faire un lanceur qui revient, ça vous l'avez vu
ça a été très médiatisé
ça a fait gagner tellement d'argent que la NASA achète à Spacex des dragons
c'est le petit vaisseau qui réapprovisionne l'ISS dans l'espace
et c'est la première fois que dans le projet de l'ISS la NASA fait appel
à une entreprise privée autre que elle même
Il a aussi présenté récemment un projet qui s'appelle la Big Falcon Rocket
et la promesse de ce truc-là c'est que t'emmènes des gens n'importe où sur la planète
en moins d'une heure.
Donc tu mets 30 minutes par exemple à faire Paris-New York
ce qui est pas dégeu !
Hum, combien coûte le billet Elon ?
En 2003, il créé Tesla vous connaissez
la célèbre marque de voiture électrique
d'ailleurs il en a chié parce qu'en 2003 mon gars personne ne croyait à la voiture électrique
tous les gens se foutaient de sa gueule, il y a plein d'interviews sur le net
il se fait rabaisser, il se fait traîner dans la boue
c'est horrible
Même le boss de General Motors se moque de lui etc.
Mais en attendant, elle est là la voiture électrique !
Bien joué Elon !
Il a aussi récemment créé l'Hyperloop c'est un train qui est capable d'atteindre les 1 000 km/h.
Il y a quelques années, il a aussi créé Neuralink
qui est une entreprise qui vise à connecter le cerveau humain à des machines
pour optimiser les performances des humains
c'est un peu creepy et flippant
et surtout il a créé un truc qu'il n'a jamais commercialisé
et j'aimerai bien savoir ce que c'est pour l'acheter moi-même
Regardez ses cheveux il y a 20 ans et regardez ses cheveux maintenant
Elon ! On sait que tu l'as le remède mais tu le gardes pour toi
petit s*laud
pour te sentir supérieur à ceux qui ont une calvitie
Et enfin, un jour il était dans les bouchons en direction de l'aéroport de Los Angeles
et ça lui a pété les c*uilles et il s'est dit p*tain mais
j'en ai marre des bouchons
si seulement il y avait un tunnel là en dessous de la route
qui permettrait d'atteindre vite l'aéroport
IL L'A FAIT !
et il a même pas attendu l'autorisation des propriétaires des maisons
sous lesquelles il y a le tunnel pour commencer à le creuser
il s'en bat les c*uilles
tu pourras descendre dans le tunnel avec ta voiture
tu te poseras sur  une plateforme qui ira à 250 km/h
et qui t'amènera au bout du tunnel
Voilà ! Il faut savoir qu'Elon Musk est très euh, il veut vraiment tout gérer
il veut vraiment la barre à lui tout seul
et il a beaucoup de mal à déléguer le travail à des gens
et c'est un truc qu'on remarque souvent chez les gens comme lui
qui ont des idées très précises, qui sont très visionnaires etc.
elles sont perfectionnistes à mort !
elles veulent vraiment que tout soit comme ils le voient
Je parle comme si je connaissais Elon Musk et c'est vrai
j'ai mangé avec lui hier et c'est faux !
Il a du mal à déléguer donc il doit gérer énormément de choses lui-même
et au bout d'un moment tu frôles un peu le burn-out voire t'es en plein burn-out constamment quoi
Ses employés travaillent comme des brutes avec énormément d'heure supp
mais ils acceptent ce rythme très soutenu parce qu'ils ont le sentiment de marquer l'histoire
What ?!
et ils adulent complètement leur patron Elon Musk
donc il y a un petit côté secte un peu creepy et glauque
mais à côté il y a des projets sensés et malins
des technologies prometteuses qui nous font rêver
donc t'es un peu le c*l entre 2 chaises en voyant ça
il n'y a pas longtemps vous avez dû le voir passer parce c'est devenu un même
Elon Musk était l'invité d'un célèbre podcaster américain sur YouTube
et après 2h d'échange où Elon Musk est assez coincé, il fait des réponses formelles
il se fait un peu chier on a l'impression qu'il n'est pas dedans, il est dans son perso d'Elon Musk.
Il commence à se détendre et le mec en face lui propose de tirer sur son joint
qui en Californie est légal
Et Elon Musk dit ok pourquoi pas pour tester
donc il tire une latte et il rend le joint
et c'est devenu un p*tain de même mon gars
parce qu'il fait une gueule après avoir tiré qui est trop drôle
et comme c'est un génie, on sait pas se qui s'est passé dans son cerveau à ce moment-là
mais mon gars il devait y en avoir des choses
Bref c'est un intellectuel visionnaire mégalo de ouf
mais à côté de ça il est vrai qu'il met en place des projets qui sont cools et utiles
qui font avancer l'humanité notamment pour Spacex son but c'est quand même d'aller sur Mars
d'ici 2025 ce qui est trèèès ambitieux et probablement irréalisable
mais lui il maintient que c'est réalisable et vous savez à quel point c'est irréalisable
depuis que vous avez vu ma vidéo sur le...
Je fais de l'auto-promo
Il y a plein d'interviews qui trainent et qui sont vraiment passionnantes et intrigantes
parce que c'est quand même un vrai génie c'est vrai quoi qu'on dise
et du coup il y a certaines de ses réponses qui sont mythiques
et trop marrantes et en plus sa manière de parler elle est vraiment particulière
enfin c'est vraiment divertissant et enrichissant de regarder des interviews de ce gars
il a par exemple déclaré qu'il y avait 20% de chances pour qu'on vive actuellement dans une simulation
et on verrait pas en fait la différence entre la vraie vie et la simulation
on est un peu dans matrix quoi
Imaginez vous donc avoir la chances de pouvoir poser une question
au grand Tony Stark, Elon Musk
qu'est-ce que vous poseriez comme question ?
et bah écoutez, il a fait en 2016 une apparition au congrès astronautique international
où il expliquait notamment tout ce qu'il développe pour pouvoir voyager sur Mars
et à la fin il finit par une petite foire aux questions quoi
et il y a des gens au lieu de poser des questions pertinentes et de se dire p*tain je vais avoir une réponse de fou
ils s'en battent les c*uilles mec, mais à un point !
regardez ça
*Rire*
C'est Elon Musk !
demande lui un truc sur je sais pas moi
Pourrons nous réussir à créer une atmosphère semblable à celle de la terre sur Mars ?
J'en sais rien mais des trucs du genre
J'ai pas la traduction exacte mais luck kiss genre un bisou pour lui donner de la chance
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça là ?
c'est Meetic qui sponsorise le congrès astronautique ou quoi là on est où ?
Ah on me dit que ça détériore l'image de la femme
Regardez bien j'ai tout prévu
Pouuuuh !
Là Elon Musk il a chaud un peu il se dit p*tain elle va me voler ma place de PDG de Spacex elle est trop intelligente
Ce petit mouv' de la tête
oh, tu sais moi les questions j'en ai répondu à des milliers hein
Haha vous êtes tous cons à côté de moi ici !
Je, désolé, je coupe ici, il est évident que ça va partir en vrille
c'est évident
Cette tête, oh nooon je suis déçu mec
moi j'adore le prout et tout se qui tourne autour du caca
Elon Musk a l'air de profondément détester
Est-ce que ça veut dire que je ne pourrais jamais être ami avec Elon Musk ?
Ah Zut !
Regardez combien de fois Elon Musk a failli prendre la parole pour dire "tais-toi"
juste tais toi stp
Ici, ici aussi et encore une fois là
Mec à l'heure actuelle, faire caca sur Mars est le dernier de nos problèmes
il y en a 800 000 autres avant
C'est du troll, il troll
il troll Elon Musk sur le fait qu'il soit égocentrique c'est tout
C'est pas du troll, oh non ! Comment tu peux commencer une phrase de premier degrés par
Bon je suis un génie comme toi et... NON
Si Elon Musk lui-meme ne s'auto-proclame pas génie, qui es-tu pour le faire ?
C'est quoi un "second look" ? Ah ok une seconde analyse de son... de ses... capacités genre
en vrai ça fait de la peine genre le mec c'est son rêve ultime et tout je suis sur il a fait des bêtes d'études
dans la vie machin et il est trop fort scolairement parlant mais il n'a pas réussi à avoir le travail de ses rêves
et il tente comme il peut quoi
En vrai c'est triste. Attends par contre je suis intéressé par comment Elon Musk va dévier ce truc là
Il va le, tu sais.. comme ça comme Goku et les Kaméhaméha *?*
Allez, apprenons de notre grand maître à tous
*Rire* Oh non il a dit la pire réponse, il a même pas essayé de contourner genre
"Ouais bah envoyez votre CV mon équipe verra et on reviendra vers vous"
alors qu'on sait que l'équipe regardera jamais le CV et n'iront jamais vers lui
il a dit non cash quitte à blesser ce pauvre être humain
Oh non ! Oh ça c'est un moment horrible, je l'ai vu il y a pas longtemps
Il y avait, je sais pas pourquoi, des gens qui le suivaient chez lui avec ses enfants, sa femme et tout
et sa femme elle sort un truc horrible devant les caméras mec
ça m'a mit à l'aise
c'est un truc qui date de 2015 et  cette époque il était avec Talulah Riley
qui est une actrice je crois, et elle parlait du fait que quand ils se sont connus ils ont très vite emménagé ensemble
et elle s'est très vite retrouvée à vivre avec 5 enfants parce qu'il a 5 enfants
Elon Musk et comment elle explique le choses devant Elon Musk c'est terrible genre
Elle vient de lui apprendre devant une caméra qu'il y a plusieurs fois où elle s'est dit
je me barre et je ne reviens plus jamais
tu n'étais pas au courant de ça, tu as beau être milliardaire et mégalo je le sais Elon
il a vraiment dit "really"
C'est pire que ce que je pensais, au moment où il dit ça sur son visage
elle y repense actuellement à le faire ça, à partir et à jamais revenir
elle a un doute regardez c'est fou
P*tain t'as beau être visionnaire, faire des voitures électriques incroyables
tu es soumis aux mêmes problèmes que tous les autres êtres humains
Oh il est passé sur un Late Show américain, je veux voir ce qui s'est dit, je veux voir
C'est glauque ce qu'il dit mec, c'est ça qui est glauque mon gars, il se prend vraiment pour le sauveur de l'humanité quoi
c'est un peu glauque hein
*Rire*
Mais, mais ça c'est pareil gros, il est rentré dans sa Tesla qu'il a fait lu-même Elon Musk
et il s'est dit p*tain c'est chiant, je perds 4 secondes à brancher le câble
mais qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire pour remédier à ça ?
Tous les jours il fait des constats de trucs qui font perdre un peu de temps
et il investit genre des centaines d'heures pour créer un truc pour remédier à ce problème
ça me tue
Et hop mesdames et messieurs vous savez ce que veut dire ce geste c'est la fin de cette vidéo
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Je trouve ça fou comme on est dans une époque où tout a vite on créé
des technologies incroyables, on dépense autant d'énergie sur quelque chose qui nous fait juste gagner 4 secondes tous les jours
Le bras là je m'en suis pas remis mec, en tout cas je trouve ça intéressant de suivre des gens comme Elon Musk
Il y avait aussi Steve Jobs qui était un gros visionnaire, Stephen Hawking aussi
Je prononce toujours mal le nom je suis désolé
je trouve ça cool de les écouter parce qu'ils ont des projets, des ambitions et une analyse des choses qui est fantastique
et en plus leur passé, leur carrière prouve qu'ils ont eu raison sur beaucoup de choses, qu'ils avaient anticipé
des trucs bien avant que ça arrive et je trouve ça remarquable et c'est toujours intéressant
de suivre ces gens qui sortent du commun même s'ils ont leurs problèmes et leurs défauts
personne 'est parfait bien évidemment
mais voilà pour notre culture à tous je trouve que c'est bien de faire cette petite vidéo
J'espère que vous avez passé un bon moment, c'est l'essentiel et on se retrouve bientôt
pour parler d'un sujet que je kiff ou de gens que je kiff ou pour jouer à un truc ou je sais pas
franchement je me fais kiffer, je suis en roue libre, incroyable !
Donc merci pour ça voilà un petit merci il fallait que je le dise
Allez on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo ou à une conférence pour poser des questions à Elon Musk
on lui posera les pires nous c'est sur, les pires
A bientôt tout le monde, Ciao !
(Peace !)